um but next up we have michelle
mannering
and she's also known as the hackathon
queen or the queen of github hello
michelle how are you
hey how's it going good now rumor has it
that you have a
particularly rare uh sample of github
stickers with octo kitty
now is that uh i do not know
what you seek but i have a very large
collection of stickers with lots and
lots of octocats so
that's awesome hopefully when we go back
to irl events
if you ever see me i always have a big
stash of stickers on me so please always
ask i will always be happy to give you
lots of
github stickers oh now you heard it here
um
now i believe that you are today going
to give us a bunch
of tips and tricks and hidden gems on
how to use github a lot better
that is correct super excited
that's awesome now i am going to monitor
the questions
uh in slider as they come in and we
might take those at the end
or and as you prefer you can also um you
know interact with the youtube
chat as well we're pretty informal here
so um i will let you
do your thing and um thanks again mesh
sounds fantastic thank you so much for
that wonderful
introduction really excited to be here
with you all it's super great to see the
chat popping off
i love watching that quiz and seeing
people get things right or wrong i
i'm from new south wales so i was like
oh somebody clicked new south wales
ndc like yay new south wales represent
uh so it's really exciting um the talk's
been great so far and i hope this one is
going to be
just as awesome for you i will be
watching the youtube chat at the same
time
um so feel free to comment i might i
might make comments of what you're
saying as well
uh but feel free to comment on um things
as we go away or
say hi and we'll take uh questions at
the end from slido
so let's jump into it right so get up
like advice so
lots of people will say oh you know
mitch what are some of your top tips
doing github so this is going to be what
they are now
um also i just realized i didn't change
my title on that one i am now the
developer advocate not developer
community manager
i was one oversight the idea that's all
good uh so
if you haven't seen me around or heard
from me
i am mish also known as mish manners
online
as i said also hackathon queen because
i've run
a multitude of hackathons now but if you
are looking for me you can find me on
pretty much any social media platform
known to men
you can find me on twitch streaming
both coding and video gaming obviously
you can follow me
on github and plenty of other places as
well
i'm on the dev roll team at github as i
said my title is now developer advocate
which literally changed like a week ago
which is why i haven't changed that one
um but yeah i'm the developer advocate
at uh github on the dev roll team we
have a few of us in australia now which
is really exciting
and it's such a great company to work at
but also an awesome product that we have
so i'm here today
to talk to you about a bunch of top tips
on how to use github how to get up like
a boss and then we'll also have a demo
as well
something that um is really fun i'll
show you some of the ways that i use
github
pretty much on a daily basis so all the
things i'm talking about are things that
i do every day things that we use all
the time and i hope they're
really exciting and useful for you too i
just love michelle's comment in our chat
actually like has all the stickers
um last time i did catch up with
michelle she did get lots of stickers so
um can confirm it's a thing
for today's top tips um i've broken them
up into a couple of sections
um so the first one we'll talk about is
personalization so
how to actually personalize github for
you next one is collaboration github is
very much known as
this social coding platform so
um yes there'll be a lot of
collaboration happening here
uh talk about the way that not just the
way i work but the way that you can work
on github and and i mentioned um a demo
as well now i've seen some couple of um
comments in the chat about the laptop
with stickers that is actually my laptop
um so yes when you do save it in person
that is literally
what it looks like okay so the first
thing on github is personalization
so i love legos i always try and fit a
photo or something about lego into my uh
presentation so i thought about this one
so in the same way you would customize
like your lego models and you build
something
um and something that's really you you
can customize your github profile too
um now one of the first things to do
that is similar to the way you do a
social media profile so
when you open up a social media account
for the first time some of the first
things you might do is go in
add a profile picture write a bit about
yourself
and just kind of like set it up a little
bit uh well you can do that now on
github too so we have this new thing
called
um a profile readme so not only can you
add
really cool things like a profile photo
and that now you can now add a readme
to your actual github profile and the
cool thing about this
is that you can add anything you like to
showcase
you you can add a file of yourself you
can add
um some of the top project you're
working on
you can add um some links to like maybe
a website that you write about
articles that you're doing um you can
obviously write some code in here
um the whole thing's written in markdown
so the sky is really the limit here in
terms of a github profile
so in order to create a profile readme
all you need to do is um create a
repository that is the same
name as your username and when you do
that you'll see that you've
like a little thing will pop up here
saying you've created a special
repository now you can
you know showcase this on your profile
is it read me
um as i mentioned it's all written in
markdown so anything you can add into
marketing pretty much adding to her
profile
um so that includes um things like gifts
this is monica's one she's got like a
cute little gift here of her optical
which i
really love and i loved it so much i
added it to mine as well
um you can add um images and you can
even
add um as i said it's coding so you can
add all these really funky things at
code
uh one thing that i've seen a lot of
people add on their profiles now is
games so like users can have actions to
set up a game that's running on their
profile and you can jump in and be part
of that game
uh which is really really fun and i say
phil dash has said that some people have
forked his
um profile really um which is generally
confusing
it kind of is but i'll show you a little
bit about that too we can jump onto
phil's one later
um but often when i'm looking for
something people say what's up some of
the best things to do for a profile
readme and to set up
one of the cool things to do is to just
look around github and when you see a
cool profile
um i often just click the edit button to
see how they've actually done it
and when you click the edit button it
forks there um
that repo so then you can actually have
a look at it copy some of the code
um as phil said it kind of kind of has a
little bit confusing because like why is
somebody forking
my personal repo but it's because they
they like what you're doing
and therefore they want to do the same
so that's one really good way about
going into
um build your profile review see what
other people do
the next one about really customizing
things is something that
not a lot of people do in github um i
often forget about it and then i'll come
back to it after a while
like well that's a good thing to
remember um is the notifications
um we've changed the way notifications
work quite a lot
um so notifications if you haven't um
see them for a while if you go into like
just github.com
and you're signed in you'll see there's
like a little bell up the top and that
is your notifications
um so you can click that and if you
haven't been on there for a while you
can click that bell
and it'll say like hey would you like to
clean up some of these notifications
you've been on here for a while
um but one of the cool things that we've
changed recently with notifications is a
better way to filter them
so because i not just work at github but
i have a lot of
organizations and teams that i'm part of
from github sometimes i want to see
certain things i want to be able to
filter certain things so for example
when
i come in on a monday i don't want to
see all this stuff from all my
weekend projects or open source teams
that i'm working with i just want to see
stuff from my github org
so i can go into the notifications i'm
filtered by the organization i can say
yeah just show me stuff from github
or from michael i wonder what my teams
specifically
say be dougie i wonder what bee doggies
um got for me
so i can go and filter by author as well
so i can go and filter that down so i
can really help
mention my notifications which is really
cool
um the next one is reminders and
reminders are really good way to control
the way you work
again i don't always want reminders um
for all my orgs so we can uh set up
reminders specific to each org that
you're part of
um and what you can even do is that
reminders that um
are linked into slack so i'm integrated
into slack so i can
set up a reminder to say like hey if i
haven't touched this issue in a few days
send me a reminder um on slack um you
can set up things like sleep bot as well
which tells you like hey no one's
touched this issue for 14 days it's
gonna close if no one does something to
it
um so you go to your profile um go and
choose the organization team that you're
part of and click on settings and
set different reminders that you need
and really help take control of your
work that way
um so as i said you can connect into
slack too and you can set
um organization settings so for example
if i only want to see
um slack notifications my github org i
can send them to my github slack or if i
wanted to set them for my open source
blog i could set them to my open source
team on slack
um which is really really awesome and i
see people
already stalking one another on how to
do stuff so
um i love that um so aaron's gotta give
up action on his profile
um to update his review whenever he
publishes a blog post i really love that
and i'll show you some of the actions i
have running on my profile as well
um now talking about personalization of
github before we jump into a few other
features
uh one of the things that people really
really ask for
and something that we launched last year
um at
universe you've probably seen this gif
making its way around the installed
video making its way around
uh this is one of our most loved tweets
when we put it out last year
um at universe was our github dark mode
which is
super exciting because um like many
people i was also
using a um like an extension fun fact
the extension i was using was open
source to available on github
but yeah i wasn't using extension but
now we have dark mode
available natively in github which is
really awesome so if you haven't seen it
you can go to your profile
and you can flip across um up the top
um on your above your readme profile and
you can flip to
darkmoon um and if you want to go into a
little bit more
if you've already used that feature um
you can flip it up in
your repository or you can even go into
your settings as well
um we also have a new dim mode as well
so if you go into
your profile settings you'll see um
there's also a dim
mode so you can have like a dark mode
like a high contrasty
type dim mode or you can have black mode
um now because i
am a huge fan of dark mode um where
possible i'm gonna be using dark mode
for the rest of this presentation
and when we do the demo i'll be using
dark mode as well
so the next one is collaboration so
here's a few ways to collaborate on
github
now one of them is project boards so
this is our project
board that is publicly available and it
shows
all our public roadmap and our project
was a really great way not just for
tracking overall progress of a project
but it's a really good way for
developers and non-developers to work
together
so with the project board you can link
to different issues you can add notes
um and it's just a really really great
way um to collaborate and it's something
that i really love
um something that is also coming you is
a new way to
see and view projects so um
this is currently available in public
beta so
for example instead of just having the
overall board you can now
add and track specific issues and see
their
status their assignees um you can see
you can add different
um categories that you want to add and
filter by
and then once you've got this kind of
like project
board type thing set up you can create
different
um views and things that as well so for
example if i like this game loop
view i can go and add that um as a new
view
here which is really cool so i can
change that to a new view and i can
always have that done you can view
things as tables and boards and this
this stuff is like super exciting these
are some new things that are coming
um another new thing that is coming
which is built into the project side of
things is task lists
so when you create an issue now and
you've got a list of tasks that you want
to do
you can go in and convert those tasks to
issues and then as you close them
they'll get ticked off
on the original uh issue which is really
exciting because lots of people
often go in and start planning for a
project they'll like write a whole list
of tasks and go hey we need actually
issues each one of these tasks so now
you can go and automatically do those
so as i said those um those couple of
features are coming soon
you can actually go in right now and
sign up for um the beta on those
um i'll show you where to do that that's
just on our um
our page for this um new project
planning stuff which is really cool
um so another way to collaborate really
well with people
on github is discussions um
so if you haven't used discussions at
all or you're not part of a
an open source repo that is using
discussions
discussions are really really fun
so with discussions you can talk about
different things
and discuss uh certain issues now the
reason one of the reasons we've decided
well
one of the reasons discussions exist
because often if you have a look back at
issues
you'll look at some issues and go wow
that thing really wasn't an issue
because an issue was really designed for
like
you know telling people what issues are
whether it's a feature you want or bug
fix or things like mostly bug fixes
right
so often people go oh you know we want
this
you know new feature request it ends up
becoming this giant big conversation
like why isn't this
uh in a forum type thing so now you can
have a discussion
about that um and if you ever find that
your issues are becoming
too much of like a conversationally type
thing you want to make it into a
discussion
um you can so you can just go in and you
can convert an issue
um into a discussion this year we've got
issues i'm like oh yeah
um this would be really cool we should
just convert it into discussions
literally a button that says
convert into discussion super easy um
so it's really exciting so discussions
can be enabled at a repository level
and some of the other project you type
things that i mentioned
like having that big giant project board
um
that has to be enabled at the
organization level so you can then track
projects across different orgs but
discussions is specific for each repo so
you can set up a discussion for each
repo if you like
uh another thing that we have that we
just launched
um publicly in beta on the 23rd of june
and is now
accessible all public repos is issue
forms
so if you are a maintainer of a project
or um you've got a team and you're like
okay every time i get my team to submit
an issue about a bug or a feature like
half the stuff isn't filled out and no
matter how
much i create a really cool template for
them to use
the half the stuff just isn't filled out
so what we've done is we've created this
single issue forms
so if you want specific things to be
added into a form um compulsory
uh you can now add those in you can add
tick boxes you can add
bullet points you can add like little
description boxes you can add categories
and things like that
so it's kind of like a google form but
it's built into issues which will make
make
things a lot easier for maintainers and
like team admins and things to start
collecting information
so um it's really cool this is something
that we'll um
go through a little bit in the demo too
so they said that was publicly available
to
um all publicly accessible repos as of
the 23rd of june it's currently in beta
so if you
have if you are using this or you end up
using it after this talk
um please give us feedback we love your
feedback so i'll show you where to do
that too
now i'm going to dive into we've talked
about some of the new features and
things that have came up um
come up from like using github and i'm
going to talk about some of the ways
that
not just we use github but i use it
firstly every day in a way a lot of our
users use github and also some of the
ways that you might want to think about
using github if you really want to take
your github usage to the next level
so the first one is github for mobile
now i
love github for mobile because it allows
you to take github with you
literally wherever you go um so it's
available on both ios and android
and since it's available on both those
platforms it's not just available on say
your mobile phone
you can also use it on your ipad um
now what i like about github for mobile
is it allows you to do a whole bunch of
different things like
quickly comment on issues reveal bug fix
merge code there's even discussions on
mobile
so we have a look at a couple of the
mobile screens like say for example this
is a home screen
um so in the morning like say on a
monday morning i wake up i roll out of
bed
um actually i don't even roll out of bed
i'm still in bed but i check my phone
uh but i can roll over in bed pick up my
phone open up github and see all right
what issues have been assigned to me
this week now
it's monday my time um so it's usually
like sunday still in the us
um but we have a whole lot of github
actions set up to
automatically open certain issues at the
start of a week so i can
wake up roll over click on my issues and
see what has been assigned to me um for
that week without even having to get out
of bed uh before i make records which is
really cool
um i could also have a look at like what
could pull requests i made might have
missed from like an open source project
or something i was working on over the
weekend
um and i can really just like look at
all these different things
and like have a really good sense of
what's happening
no i can't just i don't just have to do
this in bed obviously we've been
locked down on something anyway um but
it's really useful when you're traveling
on the go i don't always have to pull
out my laptop i can be sitting at a cafe
um or an airport and it's just like
really really easy
time to check there's also a couple
other cool things on the mobile
app like github explorer so you can see
like um
featured repositories and featured
trending things you can see like we've
got some coding interviews and stuff
um and there's even some new things that
you can see
like all our release notes straight on
mobile now which is really really
awesome i like real nasties like actions
to open weekly issues sounds really
interesting it's actually really really
useful
um so no one from my team has to go and
open an issue at the start of the week
it's just automatically done for us
um which is really great uh now the
other cool thing about mobile is we're
always shipping new features to github
um github for mobile so there's a couple
of new things that we've shipped kind of
recently as i mentioned release floats
um but now there's a whole lot of new
ways to filter things on mobile which
makes it really really
easy now going back to that whole idea
of personalization being able to filter
and manage your notifications
be able to filter all this stuff on
mobile is super
awesome so i can filter issues by um
like labels assignees i can filter
issues
um by like multiple labels as well
um which is really cool because i'm
saying is
greatly improved since you last used app
as i mentioned but always updating
mobile so if you haven't
um updated mobile in a while go and
update it um i think
the last time i gave this talk it was
like a month ago and we've already
updated it since then so
this is new since that last talk that i
gave a month ago
um and the other cool thing about some
of these filterings is i'm just looking
at the gift now you can actually filter
by emojis
which is really cool so if you want to
filter by like oh
which issues have given me a thumbs up
go check it um
so as um as you mentioned yeah we do a
lot of updates to mobile so go and check
them
go and check it out download github for
mobile if you don't have it
uh or go and update it um if you've
already got it
so it's a really great way to just use
github on the go as i mentioned
uh it's on ios and android so you can
have it on both phone ipad tablet
whatever you're using which is really
cool
um another way that i like to use um
github is github for desktop um or
github desktop which is available on
windows and mac os
now the reason i like github for desktop
is it's a really good way to manage your
repos
and when you're working on a local
um like piece of code or like a local
repository a local get
environment get off a desktop is a
really really good way to manage that
and see what you need to pull in or push
out
um as a like a non-developer by
background
um i love this because like i'll pop
into github for desktop after i've made
some changes it'll be like this big
blue button that says hey you've got
changes to push or you've got things to
pull
in and it's really really great i love
it so
um github desktop is awesome and
obviously
same thing when you're pushing online um
when you're making changes and you're
about to update your
your main branch you'll see that um you
can see all the changes that have been
made to each file there
which is something i really like so
again we're always making changes to um
desktops if you've got the desktop
version
go and check it out and make sure you're
up to date
um so if you are not super into
github for mobile or get off the desktop
um or you are a bit sick of using
github.com there's three ways um you can
use github the fourth way
which is our github cli this is
something again we launched last year
and is
constantly in development and there's so
many exciting things that are always
being done to the github cli
uh but developers are loving the cli
because it allows you to work seamlessly
in one window
um you can do so many things on the cli
you can
create edit view issues you can check
out pr's you can merge pr's
you do my personal favorite which is
coin repos
um you can now manage all your ssh keys
from cli as well which is really
um really really useful so um yeah it's
available on windows
mac os and linux so it doesn't matter
what platform you're using
um the cli is amazing um and
fun fact about the cli is the cli is
actually open source
so if you want to contribute to the cli
you can um
obviously there's no obligation for
youtube but it's a really fun uh product
use i've been using it quite a lot as
well
so speaking about using things quite a
lot i thought i'd talk a little bit
about
and show you a demo about how i like to
use github
um this is how i use github on my live
streams how to use get help in my daily
work
it's super fun so i'm gonna switch to a
demo
so if the team is stream yard can put me
on full screen
um so i can stop sharing this screen and
go start sharing
a new screen um and then give me a
second
before i actually show everything
because right now there's gonna be
some funky inception stuff going on um
all right let's pop that over there
and then cool so now you should be able
to see
my screen chat awesome so this is github
obviously uh use it in dark mode which
is really fun
um so this is my github profile readme
and there's a whole lot of cool things
going on in here
now as i mentioned you can add lots of
different things to your profile remy so
i thought i might just go really briefly
through some things
i've got um so i've got a gif which is
really fun people ask me where i got
this gift made it is actually a gift of
my room as you can see
um some of the things in here obviously
show up in the image
i got that done on fiverr so i'm not an
artist go to fiverr if you want really
cool stuff
um i added a bunch of social media links
these are just little images
another gif so if you want a github
opticat like this
you can go to my octocat
generator and build your own octa-cat um
so i will pop this link
in the chat to everyone so you can go
and build your own oxycats and go click
get started i'm just gonna move this
over to the side and you can go and
build your own opt cap which is really
really cool
um this is something we launched a
couple years ago now people absolutely
love it you can go in and
change different things and colors and
add funky tops and
do all kind of fancy things so that's
how you get that one
uh the next slide is github skyline so
if you haven't checked out
um skyline our skyline
got a lot of hype when it went live
um it feels like we did a lot last year
um so if you chuck in your username into
the little bar here and click create
skyline you'll see a 3d contribution
graph
of your github contributions which is
really awesome
so you can grab this you can flip it
around
there's some cool music i've got muted
at the moment
if you want to grab a quick gif of this
you can turn the ui
off and just see it like that um you can
also download the stl file so you can go
and 3d print it
yourself like this um or you can go and
get it printed by someone else
as well so that's really cool um then
there's some bunch of github stats and
things
and i also have some github actions
running on my profile so this is a
little snake
um it comes my profile so each every six
hours i've set this action to
generate a contribution graph um
of the last herb along and then the
snake comes along and eats it
um if you want to know how to do that i
wrote a dev
post um on how to do that so i will grab
that one for you and pop that
in the chat so this is something that i
set up and
um well i didn't set this up sorry um
something that i
wrote um on dev2
and somebody else created this amazing
action i wrote a tutorial on how to
actually
put it in um so you can see here how to
have an awesome
profile and i've linked back to here uh
which is the person who created
if you ever share any open source stuff
um or anything that someone else has
created comment
go and um shout them out this is a nice
thing to do so i've added them in here
which is really cool
um there's a bunch of codes for this
profile one there's a bunch of code
snippets on how to create an amazing
profile
so on to github itself so one of the
ways i love
to use github every day is
when i'm either coding or i want to
add some changes to a repo um
what i'll do is i'll often come into
github
see which roof i want to do make sure
it's cloned onto my personal computer
use vs code make some changes and then
push that all
up to github now i'm going to show you
the process i used
to do that and some of the different
github features because i'm one of those
people that
likes i like using all the things um so
when i use github today i'm using
the desktop the cli the web and you can
choose which way you want to use it as
well
so i have this repo set up called github
like a boss it's a public repo
that we use to do a whole bunch of demos
and cool things like that
so say if i wanted to make some changes
just read me i could obviously click
edit and make some changes but
what if i want to do it on my personal
machine first and
then make some changes and then add it
to
the rainbow some of the ways i would do
that is to make sure i have
this repo on my personal computer first
now the way i'm going to do that
is i'm going to use the cli and i'm
going to make sure i've got the github
cli installed first
by typing gh into my terminal of choice
and seeing if i've got it installed so
obviously it's installed and there's a
new version available and literally i
use this last
like a few days ago so there's new
versions all the time i can go grab the
new version
or i can just keep using it um right now
if i like
so i'm just gonna keep using it for the
moment so what i need to do
is i need to cd into location where all
my
repos are stored on my public computer
and that is not it that's my ndc file
um but if i go to my documents i've got
a folder here called git repos
so we're going to cd into that location
and we're going to clone
the repo into here so if we go
into this location and then we're just
going to go gh3 clone
hopefully this is big enough for
everyone i'll make it bigger no um so do
you hate triple coin
and then because you're using the github
cli already you don't need to write
github for this you just need to write
the name
of the repost if i was creating a github
repo
it would be github github if i was
working
um on our organization level um but this
one for my personal account so it's just
mitch manners
and it's github like up boss is the name
of the radio now if i hit that
and enter it'll say it's cloning and
it'll say
done sweet so now if i go over to my
folder
should have here beautiful we can see
it's got a little
one drive spinning thing which means it
just got added
uh now the way i like to use these is to
open them up in
um an editor of choice my editor of
choice is vs code this is something i
was working on
a little while ago um when i say a
little i got a literally yesterday so
i'm just going to close this folder
so i can open up a new one and all i can
do is i can drag
this folder that i've just cloned i can
dump it into
vs code and then it'll beautifully add
everything in with all my nice
um my nice files and everything all
right
here so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
make a change to the readme here so
let's just say
i've got ndc talk here um
and they say melbourne and um
so i've got like an image here so this
can have like a boss i usually put like
where this talk is being given so let's
just say
this one
just make a small change i'll save that
now how do i know that it has been added
to my um reaper in the cloud if i go
back
have a look and we click on refresh
we'll scroll down and there'll probably
be nothing there because
right now the change is just made on my
computer
so the way that i want to make sure
that's updated i like to use github
um desktop so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to open up this folder this
local folder in desktop
i'm going to add that repository and
sweet so it's already picked up that
i've made a change
so we can see i've made a change here
it's online 45 it's in the readme file
and i want to commit that change to my
main branch
so i can go commit so now it's committed
but it's not pushed up to the class
that's committed
is my get on my local machine and now i
want to
do is commit that to the um the clouds i
can click
push origin and it'll do some fancy
things and it'll say
yes you're all done which is awesome now
what happens if i make a change on let's
refresh that whatever happens if i make
a change on
um on the clouds let's just make a
change
uh let's make a real small one let's go
show lots of tips and tricks digging
delay and
sometimes even see a demo
well let's commit that directly to the
main branch
cool uh so someone's asking what oh
i knew i would get a question about my
vs code theme
um i'll jump into that in a second all
right so let's go to
desktop and let's have a look if there's
been any changes made
so it should give it a second
and my internet will work which should
say
there has been a change made on the
machine
and actually let's have a look here
uh it's taking a little bit but let's
open up vs code
actually know what so since aaron
already asked what theme is this
this is a really cool theme um for
bs code it's called biggest code
fortnite theme um uh
i think it was sarah and i was she was
like this is the most useless
um open source project i've ever shipped
and it's a
fortnight theme you can even have like
clouds and chickens and
if you set it up you can even have a
llama running across your screen but um
i just have the colors because i i
really like it
um so let's make a tiny change in here
and i'll show you what happens if i try
and make a change on my local
and try and push it up so if i go commit
and it should make uh there we go it's
give me an error which is perfect that's
what i want so it says desktop is unable
to push commits to this branch because
there are commits on the remote they're
not present local
you need to fetch these before
reconciling them so we'll grab them
so this is why i like desktops it does
all these things where you don't have to
think like oh what's there or what's
that command for that thing or
get push merged i don't know what it is
so this is a really good one if you're
getting non-developers to work with you
as well um i just like it because it's
got great ui
um please don't hear the lava
no i don't have the llama um i totally
did not get the lava
okay perfect that's all done and changed
which is awesome
um now one thing that we also shipped
really recently that i want to show you
before i jump back into a couple of the
other features um
was this cool thing here so
if i got a repository that i've been
working on um
so b doggy and i did this really cool
like get twitch
um theme where we built a um
chatbot interaction between github and
twitch
and i fought this repo and we worked on
it for a while now
i haven't worked on this for a little
while which is why i had to scroll quite
down quite a bit now if i have a look at
this it says
my branch is seven commits ahead of the
main but it's now eleven commits behind
b dougie's branch
um this is i love this ui github's it
tells you
like what's like how far ahead or behind
you
are and so this brand new button if you
can see how to zoom in a bit more
that says fetch up stream so i'm going
to click that and now i can just
open a pull request straight from here
um which is really cool so if you've
been working on something for a little
while
um and you have worked on it and you
come back to it you're like oh i wonder
if i
um how if i'm ahead of behind or what's
happening so you can go and fetch that
in yeah which is really cool
uh that was just something i really want
to show off because it's just it's
really cool
now i thought the other things i wanted
to talk about with some of the new
um issues stuff that we show i'm just
going to keep an eye on something about
10 minutes left for demo
um so i talked about one of the new
issues we talked about
one of the features we talked about with
issues is being able to create form
um taskers will come to forms instead
we'll create task lists
um for ad issues so say i wanna
um like you like my setup so let's um
mish wants a new setup
okay here are the things i
need for my new setup
in my room all right i need a new
personality a new computer i actually
don't need a new computer let's just say
i need a new computer
um i need some lights and
i want maybe some new i always follow
something wrong with peripherals i knew
i'd spell that wrong
it's always ph okay that's the smallest
okay cool let's go
so that's a pretty good overall project
now obviously if i was running a bigger
project or
um if i was setting up a new house for
example this let's be a lot longer but
the purpose of this then we're just
going to do three things
okay submit your issue so there we go
other guys this is pretty cool and i'm
like oh
i actually want to build my own computer
for this so i'm probably going to need a
list of that
style list now one thing i could do is
obviously go edit and add like a
another layer of list and maybe add like
a bullet points but is this probably not
going to be what i want so let's cancel
that
um that's not really what i want but oh
actually what's this new thing
okay i can convert this to an issue so
let's go and convert that to an issue
oh look there's an issue oh i say what
issues all these things
okay so now i can go into here and go oh
look there's a new issue that's been
created sweet there's no description
because obviously it just creates it
with blank so let's go right my new
computer
i want to be really bold i want a 3080
rtx ti
graphics card i want 64 gig of ram
um i also might want to buy a
heat sink oh i'll do it for the moment i
won't get too greedy right now
um gold for australia yes go for us
so say i've got these things and i'm
like cool um this task list is now
done so say i bought all these things
i'd be really ambitious
you can see the progress bar at the top
here is telling me
how many tasks i've completed and also
telling me where this issue is being
tracked
so say this issue is attracting another
issue and i can hover over that i can
see the things there
so say i've done that so all three tasks
are done now what happens if i go back
to that
issue um would that issue
be ticked off as complete for that thing
now obviously i need to refresh
um but it should be tracking it and
sometimes it works sometimes not um
there we go so i'm going to check that
off there we go one of three tasks
then i can go into my lights go cool all
right what lights do i want here
um let's go i want the new el grato ring
light
some nano leaves
like that some wi-fix lights maybe a
phillips hue
and then
wait sounds pretty cool
so let's tickle those off
um i won't tick off the last one so that
is actually a a live stream that i'm
eventually going to be doing
very soon i've got i bought a google
nest and using home assistant some fancy
github actions uh get up to manage
shopping lists you laugh
but i actually use github to manage my
shopping list
um which is really exciting um
sounds exciting i don't know all right
let's go um i want to show you
about how to do this um
the issue forms because this one's
really exciting
um we'll just do them directly in github
just uh
um for fun because i can show you the
previews as we're going
um but i set up one before here this
little test file here
what i can do is i can set up an issue
form now if you
haven't used issue templates or issue
forms before
um issue your issue templates lives
under your
github and this volatile issue template
that means whenever i open up an issue
and i see like these things here these
are all the templates here
let's say we want to create a template
um we want a new we want to build a new
issue form
so the issue forms are run on yaml files
let's go add a file create new file
um and we're going to call this um
request demo i want to i want to build a
form for rooks this is my
github like a boss i wanna build a form
for requesting
um a live demo um and i'll just do a
really short one so we can jump into a
couple of questions
um so sorry about this army one um
request a demo on this
um that did not work
there we go there we go perfect so
it says now i was like why is it not
popular this is an issue template need
help check out the documentation
um now we can obviously preview that but
it's um it's in yum also
that's all good so let's go we want a
description here i'll make it a little
bit bigger so you can actually see it
let's go right we want a description and
we're going to call this
um ask
to demo something
get hobby i'm just reading some of the
comments as i'm going
um title um let's go
request and then whatever the title
is types in and we want we can add
labels to it as well so
we want labels um
what are the labels i've got in this one
um
let's have a look uh labels so i've got
bug documentation enhancement well let's
just put money as twitch
which will do labels and we'll go
twitch and maybe
yeah feature enhancement just spell that
right
you might probably cody always spell
things wrong signings i will assign
myself to it
perfect all right so we want the body
[Music]
so we want this issue to be um done
written in mafia
we also want some attributes for it
these attributes are going to be
the form that we fill out
i don't think i spelt that wrong
again this is my problem with coding i
always
mess up the actual
spelling of things like why does my
thing not work um okay value
so the value is like the thing that we
want to give people when they feel like
thanks sir requesting a demo
we'll get back to you soon
we will get back to you soon make that
easy so don't worry about the comma
there okay now we want type so we want
this to be
um an input type um so we
want people to be able to fill out this
form so
we're going to go type this is input
so this bit up the top will be what they
say if you like a little bit of a text
which is why it's just written marked up
and this next bit is going to be user
input so let's go
um all right let's go we want some
contact details from this person
and we want to grab
their contact emails
um so let's go description
um now if you have a look at the
documentation we can make this whole bit
really easy by just um
copying and pasting some of the code
we've got um here as well so we go
syntax
for issue forms you can have a look at
all of the stuff here
um i want to wrap this up so i can
answer
a question or two um so let's just grab
all this and then we're gonna
basically copy and paste this in and we
can go
up the top here
uh demo request
i've just snuck in in the background
here mish
[Laughter]
um we didn't have any questions on
slider because you were very very very
good at answering questions on youtube
oh there we go so i'll keep going for
one more minute so we'll finish this
up identify yep just cause
no i just wonder because you went
through a million things now is there
one or two that you would pick out and
say hey if you just want to focus on
really getting some you know
productivity or whatever
these are the things you would focus on
yeah cool so if you're really wanting to
get into some of the productivity stuff
i really really like the project boards
um now as i mentioned
our um github public roadmap is
available
on project boards um and it's available
as protocols if you go and look at it
it's just
it's just really really simple and easy
now this is my
number one thing now when somebody
mentioning like the chat like oh
github shopping list i actually use a
project board like a github project
board to manage my life
and i have a column for like things that
need to get done i have a conf like
github stuff that needs to get done i
have a column for like tracking issues
that
i just want to like keep an eye on but
i'm not sure where exactly i want to put
them i have
i play a lot of pokemon goes i have a
column for pokemon go which pokemon i'm
going to be trading to my friends
that's awesome what about one for rare
octocat stickers
yeah so the roadmap go and have a look
at it as an example of how to do it but
i
i think the the projects are really
exciting which is why this um
the new the github issues is uh well
like the new project boards are going to
be really exciting
like giving you all these different
views on how to do stuff
um so i think it's really cool and um i
will once i finish up
um talking here i will pop some links
into
the chat um but basically yeah like if
you want to find out more about what's
happening
come follow us on um twitter and
youtube because they're always shipping
new features and
um yeah just hit me up on into socials
if you want to know more but
yeah it's just it's really exciting um
all the different things we're doing and
i think the new project stuff is i can i
can just i'm just absorbing your
enthusiasm it's really cool
oh thank you so much mish we're gonna um
we're gonna go to something
stretchy now actually i'm actually gonna
join in for the yoga because i'm really
nice yoga so i'm sticking around to join
you fantastic
thank you so much mission thanks for
being part of adc melbourne that's
awesome